James just set the scene for us so tell
us what you know about the movements of
the senior Royals
there hasn't been much movement at the
gates of Balmoral itself Dermot they're
they are on their way VIA Aberdeen
airport but in terms of this location
west of Aberdeen there hasn't yet been
much coming and going uh I would expect
that to change in time the first sign
today that anybody had an inkling that
things aren't great was Prince Charles's
non-departure from the bar model estate
he was due to attend a public event in
lanarkshire the helicopter that would
have transported and went in but we
understand it didn't leave with him on
board so that was the first sign locally
that all was not as it should be then of
course there was that statement from the
palace talking about concern for Her
Majesty's Health the statement said that
she is comfortable and of course this is
a part of the world this is an estate
Balmoral at which she is extremely
comfortable which she enjoys at this
time every year she is spending summer
holiday this year as she has done
throughout her life and people you know
who come across her people who meet her
and deal with her they say that it's
where she is happiest Scotland is part
of her her soul they say people who have
seen her recently in recent days and
weeks they talk about her being in good
form on Tuesday when she met and
appointed Liz truss as prime minister
they met of course in the drawing room
I'm told that in the the preamble to
that meeting it was in the drawing room
let's buy a fire big drafty room they're
obviously Keen to keep it warm for the
queen she was in good humor smile for
her press secretary and press
photographer who took those pool images
that you saw of the queen on Tuesday she
had a big smile for them joked about the
weather talked about how dark it was
you'll remember on Tuesday it was
bucketing down here well as trust is
plane couldn't lie on for something like
20 minutes because of the conditions the
queen remarked on that too the press
secretary and photographer only had a
joke about it she was in good spirits
she was jovial uh waited around two or
three minutes for one's trust to arrive
I had a big smile for the incoming prime
minister and thereafter
um she sat back down she was using a
stick that day but we've seen the
pictures she was all smiles and again
people who were there and who met her in
person said that she was in uh jovial
mood but clearly her condition has
changed since then and we have this
statement from the palace that there is
concern for her health but that she is
comfortable behind the Gates of the bar
model estate
James Matthews in Balmoral thank you